[Aplausos]
tomar acción o no tomar acción todos
tenemos la posibilidad de ser agentes
pasivos y simplemente recibir lo que la
vida no está o ser agentes de cambio y
aceptar que tenemos la posibilidad de
usar nuestro talento al servicio de
otros cuando me refiero al servicio no
me refiero al servilismo sino que a
través de hacer algo que nos encanta que
nos apasiona que nos mueva también
podamos ayudar a otros
en mi caso algo que me marcó muchísimo
fue el hecho de convertirme en mamá esto
me motivó a hacer lo que hoy en día hago
a través de convertirme en mamá conocí
mi capacidad infinita de amor y también
comprendí la responsabilidad que esto
conllevaba
fue hasta que fui mamá que yo entendí
que importante es que una mamá esté
presente en la vida de un niño
especialmente los primeros años de vida
cuando podemos sellar los con amor y
fundar las bases de ese ser humano que
va a ser en el futuro
también aprendí la vulnerabilidad de los
niños
y en algún momento es ya con todo mi
corazón poder tener un superpoder que me
permitiera cuidarlos a todos porque aquí
creo que todos los presentes van a estar
de acuerdo conmigo que cada niño en el
mundo debiera tener la oportunidad de
ser amado y de ser de sentirse seguros
pero que podía hacer yo
para contribuir al bienestar de los
niños si no tenía más experiencia que
con los míos no soy doctora obviamente
no tenía un superpoder no soy psicóloga
no soy maestra ni siquiera cuento
cuentos
pero yo tuve la ventaja de tener una
abuela maravillosa que me enseñó que por
la vida no se va pensando en lo que no
tenemos sino en lo que sí tenemos y
haciendo lo mejor con esto y que es lo
que yo tenía aparte de las ganas
conocimiento de diseño
elaborados con técnicas manuales
entonces con estas herramientas decidí
empezar mi emprendimiento que es
enfocado a empoderar madres de familia
para que a través de ellas poder aspirar
a que sus hijos tengan una mejor calidad
de vida
inspirada en esto empecé mi empresa
lo que yo soy diseñador actuación al y
lo que hago es diseñar desarrollar y
comercializar productos elaborados a
mano por comunidades de mujeres que
viven en el área rural muchas de estas
en zonas de alcorta o riesgo
mi enfoque es empoderar las a través de
darles un trabajo sostenible
y desde que creé me interesa tuve
siempre bien claro cinco principios bajo
los cuales desarrollo todos los cuales
son hechos a mano
elaborado con técnicas tradicionales con
materiales ecoamigables enfocados al
empoderamiento de la mujer a través del
comercio justo y la innovación a través
del diseño estos cinco principios son
muy importantes para mí pero hoy vengo a
hablarles en particular del
empoderamiento de la mujer y de la
importancia que éste tiene y de los
resultados maravillosos que ha tenido en
mi proyecto
yo creo firmemente que cuando tocamos la
vida de una mujer tiene
algo transformador y maravilloso y no
solo tocamos la vida de ella sino que
también estamos tocando la de sus hijos
y las de sus comunidades
las oportunidades para las mujeres en el
área rural de nuestro país son
prácticamente inexistentes si quieren
encontrar una mejor calidad de vida
tienen que mirar a la ciudad más cercana
o en casos extremos en eeuu y en esta
realidad ven a sus hijos cada 15 días o
indefinidamente los dejan a cargo de
familiares y yo creo que en esta
desvinculación familiar cuando tantos de
nuestros problemas sociales que tenemos
hoy en día empiezan
a mí me impactó muchísimo con conocer
la cantidad de salvadoreños que emigran
diariamente a eeuu son alrededor de 300
diariamente muchísimo este porcentaje
son mujeres madres de familia otro dato
muy triste que me pareció que me partió
el alma en realidad es saber que según
la organización save the children somos
el país más violento para un niño
conocer esta realidad de mi país de las
mujeres y de los niños me hizo sentir en
un principio que no importaba cualquier
cosa que yo hiciera nunca iba a ser
suficiente
se han sentido ustedes en alguna
situación así que quieren hacer algo que
los motiva que dicen esto va a ser
maravilloso yo puedo pero de repente en
el problema gigante y esto nos paraliza
pues yo les digo algo hay que empezar
por algún lado y fue lo que yo hice
porque aunque me di cuenta que yo no
podía cambiar toda esa realidad de las
mujeres y de los niños lo que sí podía
hacer era usar mi talento y mi
conocimiento para cambiar aunque sean
unos pocos y es así como empecé
trabajando con seis mujeres y ahora
después de siete años somos más de 70
entre fijos y eventuales
todo eso lo hacemos bajo normas de
comercio justo ya que no percibo que
estas mujeres simplemente sobrevivan de
su trabajo sino que mejoren su calidad
de vida
a través de hacer té y desde el diseño
hemos logrado la innovación constante de
nuestros productos y eso nos ha
permitido posicionarnos en mercados
nacionales e internacionales exportando
a más de 70 tiendas en 15 países
diferentes esto nos ha permitido lograr
tener un trabajo constante para las
comunidades que era uno de nuestros
retos principales también hemos sido
invitados a exponer nuestros productos
en la antesala de los premios emmy
grammy y oscars y últimamente en el
festival de cine de cannes miren es
bellísimo ver de primera mano un arito
que ha sido que yo sé que ha sido
elaborado en una comunidad rural del
salvador
por ejemplo cara sucia por doña josefina
pérez
verlo exhibido en la alfombra roja el
festival de cannes por un artista
internacional sólo nos hace asegurarnos
una vez más que como salvadoreño podemos
llegar hasta donde ni nos imaginamos
para mí es un honor estar ahí en estos
eventos y poder decir que estoy
salvadoreña no estoy ahí solo como lula
estoy representando a nuestro país de
una manera positiva y eso me llena de
orgullo y de felicidad porque digamos si
no se siente rico es decir que en este
país saben que pasan cosas maravillosas
que hay gente increíble haciendo cosas
super positivas
[Aplausos]
a través bueno yo creo que como
salvadoreños perdón y como diseñador en
general todos tenemos la obligación no
sólo de crear respuestas
de uso y estéticas sino que también
debemos de hacerlo con una conciencia es
el medio ambiente respetando la
naturaleza minimizando nuestro uso de
recursos minimizando nuestros
desperdicios y si a esto también podemos
sumarle el hecho de poder generar un
cambio social esto para mí es el diseño
sostenible
y el trabajar bajo estas filosofía nos
ha permitido empezar a ver los cambios
importantes para mí en atrás de las
comunidades que son los cambios sociales
como por ejemplo el empoderamiento de la
mujer
a través del empoderamiento económico
estas mujeres se han llegado a convertir
en las mayores proveedoras de sus
hogares
permitiéndoles tomar las decisiones
importantes sobre su vida cómo mandar a
sus hijos a la escuela o darles una
mejor salud
la media en el área rural es que cuando
los niños terminan quinto grados dejan
de estudiar ya estudiaron la primaria y
es suficiente ya saben leer y escribir
entonces los niños se van a trabajar el
campo con sus papás y los niños se van a
la casa a ayudar en las tareas
domésticas y tal vez ayudar a cuidar a
sus hermanitos y en esa realidad su
única aspiración se convierte en ser
madres pero todos los hijos de las
mujeres que trabajan con nosotros tienen
la opción de eso y están recibiendo una
educación más allá de quinto grado este
año tendremos la tercera generación de
graduados de bachillerato
miren ver el rostro de una mamá sentirse
orgullosa y que se le iluminan los ojos
al contarte que a través de su esfuerzo
ella ha podido dar la educación a su
hija y que será la primera bachiller en
toda la historia de toda su familia es
lo máximo
otro de los cambios tangibles e
importantes que podemos ver que nuestro
proyecto está teniendo es en la vivienda
todas las mujeres que empezaron a
trabajar con nosotros han logrado
construir sus casas
anteriormente tenían que compartir su
misma casa una misma casa con diferentes
núcleos familiares
hoy cada quien tiene su espacio privado
y claro que eso les da un sentido de
privacidad y de mejor calidad de vida
pero saben qué es lo que a mí me
impresiona más y me alegra más tal vez
es el hecho de que ellas al ser al báder
aportado económicamente para la
construcción de sus casas les da un
sentido de pertenencia y de dignidad que
no tenían antes los jóvenes de la
comunidad también están cambiando su
pensamiento y ya no sólo aspiran a mirar
a eeuu para tener una mejor calidad de
vida porque están viendo que esta
oportunidad la pueden tener dentro de su
misma comunidad
y los cambios que para mí son bien
importantes porque son bien difíciles de
lograr y son como bien invisibles son
los cambios de esquemas sociales
al principio los esposos y los
compañeros de vida todas estas mujeres
que trabajan con nosotros no las
apoyaban no estaban de acuerdo en que
ellas trabajaran
y ver a esos mismos hombres que no las
apoyaron hoy que ya entendieron y
vivieron los beneficios de esto verle el
cambio de mentalidad ver que están
ayudando en las tareas del hogar que
están ayudando a cuidar a sus hijos que
están cocinando cena hay uno que está
cafecito la lleva con pan dulce en las
tardes
yo de verdad en el área rural de nuestro
país donde el machismo está
completamente arraigado esto es un
verdadero cambio de esquemas sociales y
estoy segura que van a haber muchísimos
más
y los cambios que no son tan visibles
o no son tangibles pero no por esto son
menos importantes es ver a estas mujeres
empoderadas felices creyendo en ellas
mismas cuando miren al principio tenían
miedo hasta de venir a san salvador- hoy
ver leyó ese cambio de actitud de cómo
se ven ellas mismas de cómo se proyectan
verlas como están rompiendo los esquemas
sociales para mí es maravilloso y es un
privilegio para mí trabajar con ellas he
aprendido tanto son mujeres con tanto
coraje imagínense yo les admiro de mil
maneras imagínense que todos sus
familiares todos sus parientes todas sus
comunidades les dijeran ahí no no lo vas
a lograr es que no lo debiera de hacer
y ellas a pesar de eso
se tomaron el riesgo
se lo tomaron como un reto
y lo convirtieron en una oportunidad y
de verdad que están cambiando su calidad
de vida y la de sus hijos y lo más
importante creo yo es que están abriendo
el camino a las nuevas generaciones
yo los invito a ustedes a todos los que
están aquí presentes a quien su vida
compartan eso que les encanta hacer con
una persona por lo menos
porque si compartimos eso que nos
encanta hacer nuestra pasión vamos a
compartir algo que amamos y las cosas
hechas con amor tienen efectos
maravillosos pero eso sí yo creo que el
punto desde el que lo hagamos tiene que
ser genuino porque la solidaridad es
voluntaria
y con un énfasis muy claro de no hacerlo
de manera existencialista
sino que de manera horizontal donde
todas las partes involucradas son igual
de importantes
nosotros lo hemos logrado a través de
empoderar a mujeres madres de familias
dándoles la oportunidad de trabajo
volviendo a las partes de una cadena
productiva de valor reconociendo las a
ellas mismas como agentes de cambio
social con dignidad y capacidad
enfocándonos en lo que sí queremos que
es en la calidad de vida
que para mí se traduce a tener la
libertad de tomar
diferentes decisiones que no estén
basadas en el miedo
y es a través de esto que ellas están de
verdad transformando su vida han
transformado la vida de sus hijos la de
sus familias las de sus comunidades y
por qué no soñar algún día la de todo un
país
hoy los invito a que hagamos lo mejor
que podamos con lo que sí tenemos a
donde estemos y con quién estemos
gracias
[Aplausos]